a source tells ET Megan gets all the
credit for snapping this sweet pic of
seven month old Archie with Daddy Harry
on Thanksgiving the never-before-seen
photo was taken at a waterfront property
on Vancouver Island where the family has
been celebrating the holidays with
Megan's mom
Doria Ragland that's where our source
says the couple has been seen jogging
hiking and enjoying time with friends
and family Megan and Harry shared the
photo in their 2019 year-in-review video
on Instagram among the highlights
Archie's christening the family
captioned the post quote we hope 2020
brings each of you health and continued
happiness
Archie looks pretty happy and his comfy
ugg boots and cute knit cap our source
reveals the boots were one of the very
first gifts given to Harry and Megan
during their Australian tour just after
she confirmed her pregnancy meanwhile
the royal family's Christmas photo is at
the center of some controversy with
claims that Megan's face was altered to
be in sharper focus than Harry's Megan's
pal
The Morning Show star Janina gavankar
took the picture and she lashed out
saying quote I see your campaign against
my friend continues nice Photoshop of my
non photoshopped image
[Music]